[Music]
let us choose wisely and how we remember
this past year let us remember those who
we lost and those who we found again
let us remember the times where our
faith in humanity was tested and those
moments and those people who helped us
restore it
let us remember how helpless we can be
in the face of nature
[Music]
and how helpful we can be to each other
when it lashes out
let us remember what has been sacrificed
for the things that we believe in
[Music]
let us remember the moments of swelling
a heart bursting joy
in the past we took to get there let us
remember how some of our ancestors
screwed up and remind ourselves from
time to time to leave the place in order
for our children's children and when big
things happen and catastrophe strikes
let's remember that we're all vulnerable
in one way or another we're all part of
that story
and maybe that the best way to weather
the uncertainty of years to come
as with each other
let us remember that there are countless
ways that we can help each other
become each other's heroes
this year and every year
[Music]